Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It is time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
September 26th,
2016 what's going on? Oh Wow. Yesterday,
September 25th was the 36th anniversary
of the death of John Bonham.
Why do I know that? Because
I'm a nerd. Um, all right,
let's get into the podcast this week.
Now.
I don't have a lot of time to fucking
sit here and try and brighten up you God
damn Monday.
Okay.
I've been doing these
podcasts for since 2007.
All right.
At some point I have to kick you people
out of the nest and you have to learn
how to find your own chuckles,
your own happiness on a Monday.
Um, I don't know. I'm talking about
anyways, let's just get right into it.
People last Thursday evening,
if you owned a television
and you had it on, okay.
If you're not one of those annoying
readers, you know what I mean?
You know annoying readers are,
they can't just go and do it.
They got to let everybody know. You know,
I don't watch TV. Oh, good. Good. Well,
guess what,
now we have nothing to talk about
because I don't give a fuck about, uh,
you know, this, I this a little, I read,
I can't even name an author other than
like Stephen King and I know he's not one
of the classics, you know.
Well, maybe he will be someday.
Maybe the dead zone will
be right up there with a,
who's the guys fuck Crispus addicts set
the guy who started the revolutionary
war. Was he the first guy who was
killed or did he write scrooge?
Now what the fuck was that guy's name?
And now I know it was Christopher
Christopher something.
I read the fucking book.
I read it,
you know something.
I read a bunch of classics as I was sick
of people bringing them up and I didn't
know what they will, you know, the,
the, the, the prince and the pauper.
I read that one. I read, uh,
the Count of Monte Cristo,
which was like a fucking 600 page book.
I read the whole fucking thing
with my add. I mean, it took,
it took forever. Um, great book. Uh,
I give it a thumbs up Moby Dick.
I couldn't get through the fucking
thing cause they kept breaking down,
wailing like I had nothing better to do.
Right?
Like there was no TV and internet
and all that shit in my life.
Like back the books from back then if you
get like the original like copy of it,
like how it was actually written.
You understand the astounding
level of fucking boredom.
You know, you just, you had no, you didn't
have a car, you didn't have any money.
You'd be lucky if you had fucking shoes.
Okay.
And if somebody was nice enough
to actually teach you how to read,
you had a book like your
heart was fucking racing.
Oh my God. If I have a
book right and you fucking,
you get excited. You know, you always that
book, one of those Huck Finn, Tom Sawyer,
things they give you whitewash the
whole fence. We'll give you an apple.
And he was excited.
There weren't any,
snickers is a fucking apple nature.
Sugar is a sake. Right? And he
was all fucking independent.
All fucking fence for an apple.
I love the apples are free.
Just walk up to the God damn
train. You take it. Right.
So I got this country was taken right.
We just walked wide up. We just talk it.
Hey, you guys were already here.
Yeah, move out. Clear, clear it out.
Keep Bobot back it up.
Back it up. White people,
right?
It's probably the nicest way
genocide was ever described.
Hey, could you guys just back it
up a little bit? Um, yeah, but now,
now you know,
now there's no reason to read and pretty
soon there's going to be no reason to
even interact with other human beings.
Now when they make these not only these,
these sex suits that they're
working on so vigorously,
I believe in Asia. As far as the
video said, I've seen no, no.
None of this believer it or not.
It's really been researched.
I can't remember who the fuck that was
one of you lunatics who sent me the thing,
or if I saw it on TV,
I never remember how I get information,
but I distinctly remember seeing
somebody laying down in his suit.
It actually, it might've been the writer's
room and F is for family. I don't know.
I don't have any fucking short
term memory anymore. Right.
It's probably all the
fucking Gmos in my food.
According to the Hippie people down
there at the farmer's market who go,
look man, this is, this is how
big a chicken supposed to be, man.
It was fucking Gmos, man. Um,
I dunno if this GMOs in my food or not.
You know why? Cause they're flavorless.
You can't taste them. You'd
think if somebody was putting
something in your food,
you'd be like, oh, well what is that? What
is that? I don't know how their flavors,
it's kind of weird.
Anyways,
the fuck was I talking about?
Oh yeah.
So this fucking guy was laying down
in s it looked like he was, uh,
he was wearing one of those, remember
that gimp from at Tarantino movie, right?
Fast Times at Ridgemont high with the
fuck is a pulp fiction right there.
The gimp. And we had a gimp suit
on, except it was like white.
And I don't know if they just
covered up his face so you,
he wouldn't know his identity.
But he was like, he had this,
this fucking mummy thing on.
He had the virtual reality glasses and
then there was something on his dick.
I Dunno what I was doing.
It was like the fleshlight except
there was the automatic version. No,
be a flashlight is automatic.
That's battery powered. Right.
That is the creepiest God damn
fucking thing in the, in the,
in the history of man,
I'm a Thomas doing a podcast.
This person had one and he goes, look at
this, check this account. It was like,
it was like he put your Dick in that
anyways to do was just lay it in that when
I'm trying to say is they're working on
these fucking virtual reality sex suits.
Okay. So once these stakes, they
get them to a fucking level.
Like look how good they've
made video games. Okay.
And I haven't played since grand theft
auto three because that game was so
fucking great. It just took over
my life. I can't imagine what it's,
what they like now.
So what I'm saying is,
okay,
once they have the sexy things
going on, like the, you're going to,
you're going to deal with your wife.
Yeah.
Does she even have a wife?
Okay.
I don't wanna hear that horse shit about
companionship and Blahblahblahblahblah
and all of that crap.
You get that all out of the way
when you put on your mommy suit.
You know what I mean? You laid out,
you fucking dial up whatever you, yeah,
I want to, I want to be in, I
want to be in a pizza parlor.
I want to have fucking Mozzarella sticks,
fright and then use chick comes over and
goes, here's your check in. And I say,
yeah, he got the money and
then for some reason she, yeah,
blows me,
but it can I dial up where I can actually
also be eating the Mozzarella sticks
and, and you know, Siri will
be in there and be like,
I don't think that'll be a problem.
Dang.
And then it's going to be happening when
you can fucking do that in the future.
It's a wrap. It's fucking
over. You know what I mean?
I wonder if he gave like a sex offender,
like one of those suits,
what he'd stop fucking trying to
snatch people, you know, be like, dude,
dial up whatever you want. You fucking
lunatic. Just stay away from us.
Okay.
Probably wouldn't, you know what I
mean? Cause at the end of the day, oh,
you know, something, you know,
it'd be fucking hilarious.
His book readers would actually still be
fucking real. People pick. Yeah. You know,
I don't have a sexy when I'm
just, I like the actual, you know,
I thought the person was better.
It's like we just shut the fuck up.
Wow. I don't know what the hell just
happened. I don't know how I got on that.
What does that fucking eight minutes a
shit. All right. 52 to go. It's not bad.
I was saying, if you were near a
television view and Eric Goddamn TV,
do you have a TV in your life? Okay. If
you're not one of these fucking readers,
these people who are informed, these
people who know who their governor is,
you know what I mean? They
know all the words to the
national anthem. Uh, you know,
they've memorized all the flags around
the world. You know, those people,
they just can't get enough of
doing excrutiatingly boring things.
You know, they, they fucking,
they the kinds of people that when
they buy something they like read the
instructions, the whole
fucking book. Leanne,
they know how their whole phone works.
All of these are all,
these are all the people that you know,
you don't really hate them,
which is you really,
you hate yourself because you
know that doing the right thing.
There's nothing worse than when you're
a fucking dope like me to be near
somebody that is doing the right thing.
Cause when you see them
doing the right thing,
there's that voice in the back of your
head that you really try to drown out.
You know that saying like, Bill, that's,
that's what you should be doing. You know,
you should be doing that. Right.
You know, if you did that, you know,
you'd stop having these ridiculous rants
about technology and how fucking stupid
it is.
The reality is,
is you lacked the focus to get
through an eight page pamphlet,
most of which are pictures with arrows
pointing at the shit that the words are
talking about. You can't get through
that and this person reminds you of that.
So rather than being a fucking adult
and just sitting down and opening the
fucking booklet, you start yelling
at the thing like it's a person.
This is really just sort of therapy.
I tried to set up apple TV the
other day and uh, you know,
I just, I know how I am now. I just
told my wife to do it. She's like,
I have to do it. I said, yeah,
you have to do it right. She
goes, why I go, cause you,
you are, you're wired. No Pun intended,
better than I am for these types of
situations. Right? So she fucking, uh,
I'll, I'll break down right here. The
difference between me and my wife, right?
She fucking got in there. So I'm
sitting out in the backyard, right?
Drinking a Miller and she's in
there and I'm just listening to her,
sort of talking out loud,
figuring it out.
And then she got to one point
and it fucked up. And then she,
she laughed and went, oh no, oh.
Or something like that. And I said,
I would never ever emotionally be there.
I would,
that right there is where I'd be like, Oh,
what the fuck? Fuck this. Fuck. You know,
I would flip out, she just left. Okay,
now here's the difference between us.
So the last night I'm at a
buddy's my house house, right?
It was like eight of us and we'll
fucking smoking a cigar and a,
or cigars. I say we're not
passing around like a joint,
which is why I never got into
smoking weed. It's like I,
it was the most disgusting thing is
I think gets passed around and Shit,
you know, I was always sitting
there like, is, can I have my own,
no offense fellas, you know,
I really like you guys,
but could I have my own that
they'll only my mouth touches?
Um, it's fucking dirty. Hippy,
fucking Putz. Smoking sons a BS. Um,
so we're over there and we're fucking
smoking and somebody just points,
he's got this big window and his house.
And His light is on and somebody points
to the window and he's like, dude,
what the fuck?
And we look and this is mouse like
climbing up the fucking window.
And ironically enough we were just
talking about working with monkeys,
you know,
in movies and shit and like in a wild
animals and stuff and I was talking about
I would never fight. That's
a deal breaker. I don't
give a fuck how much money,
there's no fucking way I'm working
with the monkey because those things
routinely fucking just stay snap. You
know what I mean? Everybody looks at,
Oh look,
he's got a little hat on and a vest
somehow it's not a chimpanzee anymore.
That is the ability to rip my
foot off my body. Fuck that thing.
Fuck that thing. All right,
I'm not working with it.
I just got done saying that and then
when we saw the mouse it all went out the
fucking window.
Okay.
You saying, you know we're trying
to corner this thing, right?
This is when you really realize what
people are like when you get into like a
crisis like this.
So I got this Tupperware thing.
I don't know why I didn't grab
like a mock panel or something,
but I'm in shorts and shit.
And all I'm thinking is that
this fucking thing bites me.
Do I got to get those 70
rabies shots to the stomach?
MMM.
And I'm sitting there,
right?
The fucking liberal trying to capture
this thing and shoot out the window.
And then my buddy, that conservative
is fucking goes. He literally,
the things went up to, uh, the
curtain and was way up on the car.
And this guy's got this fucking,
it was like 12 foot fucking ceilings,
this old house, you know? And uh,
it's all the way up there on the
curtain and the conservative dude goes,
get some wd 40 in a match.
It's like any serious, it's like, dude,
you want to burn these? Do you want to
hear the sound of a mouse burning alive?
You want that on your fucking hard drive.
Not to mention it's on curtains.
You know,
W I don't know what sort of sniper
you think I am with this fucking shit.
I'm not doing that. So anyways, so
the thing fucking like lightning quit,
like I threw the Tupperware, added it
to get it to crawl back down the car.
And we're like, where is it? Where is
it dude in like fucking Barry Sanders,
Zig zags between all of us takes off
down the hall and goes through the only
open door into the bathroom. So they're
my buddies in there. He's got it,
he's got like the fucking Tupperware
thing and I'm going and I'm going to close
the door, close the door. But
it's, he doesn't want to be,
I don't close the door and be in there
with the fucking vows cause it's still
creepy. So I'm going shut the fucking
door, shut the fucking door and
he won't shut the door and all of a
sudden the thing starts running out and I
gave it the old fucking right pad.
Save, kicked it back into the room,
right. It was like kicking a soc two
you could bucket, barely feel it.
I'm sure it felt different to the mouse
and it was hilarious and fucking fucking
head. My buddy right in his knee
and he was wearing fucking shorts.
And he fucking dad jumps up in the air
and then the fucking thing ran out again.
Got down on the stairs and
I'm fucking good. Like what?
This Tupperware thing going,
bump, bump, bump, bump, bump,
trying to get the fucking thing. And
then finally like, and where it ran,
like there wasn't a good amount
of light and I fucking had it.
I heard it's squealed and they turned
the light on and I got the thing down and
the things on its back looking up on me,
it's whole body is in the top where,
and I'm right down on its neck and it's
just looking up at me and I gotta tell
something right now. The thing was
fucking adorable. Fucking adorable.
So I was able to,
you know,
quickly get his fucking head in there
and then the things in there like making
this squealing noise and I'm like, uh,
I'm, I'm sorry buddy. Sorry
Buddy. We're almost there.
And I just slid it across the floor.
It was freaking out.
So I get it all the way to the
door. And then there's, you know,
that that piece of wood there
between the door and outside.
Now I've got a fucking lifted up.
I start to lift it up immediately.
It's fucking gross tail was
sticking out and I'm like, fuck,
if this thing runs back in the house, then
we got to do this shit all over again.
Oh, now what if I get bit?
So I just held it down, uh,
the Tupperware thing down and I sort
of stood up with my hand still on it,
brought my foot back,
close the door as much as I could and
I just fucking booted the thing and it
just took off like a maniac down
the driveway and the mouse lived,
lived to tell another fucking tail.
And um,
that's what I'm good at. You get a
fucking mouse in the house. I'll fucking,
I'll get out some top of where and
I'll fucking get rid of it. All right.
But if you want me to set up apple TV,
like,
okay.
I actually enjoyed catching the mouse.
I was never like,
even when I was running around,
I wasn't frustrated.
I never felt that he anger
when I saw the mouse there,
I didn't have any urge to kill it.
I thought it was fucking adorable.
And then I just let it go.
And the mindset I was in that entire
time during that dead, you know,
moderately challenging point in my life.
If I could just be in that mindset when,
you know,
I'm trying to fucking download something
or anything like that, I, I feel like,
I feel like my wife would have like
70% less shit to complain about when it
comes to me.
You know what I mean?
That could just somehow
getting that mindset was fun.
Run around you get the blood going.
Like when we all went back,
we all went back to smoking cigars were
all laughing our balls off, you know,
afterwards guys going are you fucking did
this, uh, you were scared and blah, blah,
blah. And then we were like, what
the fuck said, get wd 40 and a match.
And we all just started
laughing. We're like, dude,
you're definitely vote for Trump. Get his
coat, get his coat, take his coat. Right.
Um,
so anyways,
so I've been beginning to like
delegate now, Shit like that.
I'll just like it because my wife, you
know your wife. Okay. And you know,
women in general, women in general
are just inherently fucking lazy.
They don't want to do shit.
It's like they're lazy.
They're just too fucking smart
to have to do most of the shit.
And if they have a guy in their life,
he's dumb enough to fucking do it.
So all they gotta do is a couple little
pouty face fucking things and they get
to sit on the couch. Right. And
that's why they're always saying, oh,
it's easier for you to lose
weight. It's like, no, cause,
cause every time there's a fucking
country job, yeah, I got to go do it.
Can you take the recycling
out? That's cardio, sweetie.
Why am I always on the fucking elliptical
anyways?
Um, that was not, none of this was
what the fuck I wanted to talk about.
What I wanted to talk to you about is if
you are near a fucking TV on Thursday,
all right.
And you already sort of have any sort
of a God damn American you put on what?
Bup. Bup, Bup, bup,
bup, bup, bup, bup, bup,
banner.
Bam.
You put on a dog,
just started wagging its tail like what
I was doing somehow had something to do
with her. Um, do you watch Thursday
night football and what you saw,
what you saw,
what Patriot fans saw?
What Cold Fan saw?
What Jim?
The fucking biggest baby in NFL history.
Jimmer say.
Saw where's the solidification?
If that's even a word of a man.
Big like undeniably he became that night.
The greatest coach of all time.
Okay. That's it. It's not even debatable.
You know how it's not debatable.
Even people who hate the Patriots
can't criticize bill Belicheck
anymore. All they say is like, oh,
that guy could win with, don't. You could
be out there and he could win with you.
So they have to sort of shit on Tom Brady.
That's the closest you'll get a patriot
hater to say that bill Belicheck is the
greatest coach of all time.
He has to stay up to somehow take away
Tom Brady who fucking drove his team to
the go ahead score in all six Superbowls
that he was in with under two minutes
left two times.
No disrespect to Eli.
His defense failed them. I can have a
takeaway from me like Eli beat us, right?
Well the front fort beat the first time,
but you don't what I'm saying.
But when Tom had the fucking ball, he
didn't, he didn't kneel O'Donnell. It,
he,
Joe Montana does to six fucking
times six for fucking six.
I don't give a fuck how
great a coach you are.
You can't teach a guy to fucking do that.
And all these fucking dopes
out there who are acting like,
cause we beat the Texans in week three.
Okay.
That's the same fucking thing is uh,
you know,
doing it the first week in
fucking February. Um, but anyways,
yeah.
What you're really seeing
an in new England is,
is the greatest coach of
all time to devastation.
Devastating combination of the
greatest fucking coach of all time.
Okay.
To arguably top three,
four quarterback of all time.
Okay.
All right. Cause I'm open, Johnny
Unitas, Joe Montana, Joe Montana,
need four temps to win four
Superbowls, not six, you know,
so I give him the edge there and there's
always some other fucking guy and need
somebody that somebody can give me a
good argument for. And I say, all right,
the fucking thrown this at times.
Like what a four or 500 fuck you want to
say yes. Even if you put them at five,
that's still, you know,
ridiculous. All right.
And then our owner I think is on his way
to be in top three owner of all time.
And if you want to fucking argue with me,
here's his three coaching hires
since he's been there. Bill Parcells.
Oh Pistol Pete Carroll.
Before anybody knew pistol
Pete was a fucking great coach.
He hired him and bill Bellacheck.
Okay.
Bill Parcells, Pete
Carroll, Bill Belichick,
and fucking 26 years old and team,
24 fucking years old team.
That's who the fuck he's had his
quarterbacks drew Bledsoe and fucking Tom
Brady. All right. So,
so all you people that will try to make
it seem like it's just one person like
you need, you need all three components.
You got to have to have the ownership,
you've got to have the coaches,
and you got to have the fucking players.
All right? However, of the
three headed monster there,
one of them is without a doubt,
the greatest of all time.
And that is bill Bellacheck.
And that's why I actually tweeted that
Patriot fans are actually enjoying the
suspension more than Jim or say,
and it's fucking true because all it,
if we fucking somehow beat the
bills next week, all right,
now the pacet is fucking
fucked up his thumb.
And we're going to have
to Edelman at quarterback.
And if you looked at the highlights of
Edelman playing quarterback at Kent State,
you understand why he was not
drafted as an NFL quarterback?
Because there's no fucking
way he would've survived.
Half of the highlights are him
running all over the God damn field.
Um, and then the other half is
him on his fucking tippy toes,
throwing the God to both trying to see
over the fucking Leiman or whatever.
Like I like, I know what a quarter of
professional quarterback it looks like.
I'm just saying the second I see a
guy running around all over the field,
it's like, yeah, you're not going to
do that long in the NFL. Um, cause you,
they may, they may get,
I'll get you the first week.
They might not get you the second, they
might not get you for a couple of years,
but one of those days
they're going to get you, oh,
they're going to get you and they're
going to fuck you up when they do.
And all it takes is that one fucking
hit and all of a sudden you lose half a
step and then you fucked. Okay.
Because all that time, you know,
I feel like that all that time you've
been fucking running around just felt like
that guide reservoir dogs,
you know,
so you like to tell jokes giggling
like a bunch of school goes,
well I got a joke for you.
12 guys sitting around and Wolpert and
wonder why the fuck they got there.
What did we do? What should we have done?
All of a sudden they realize, you know,
okay,
all the time we joke around with,
she'd been planning this Cape Off.
Well then fuck it goes. So anyways,
the guy who loses a half fucking steps,
same thing, he starts taking your
oil. At time I was wanting to rob,
I should have been learning
the fucking position.
And now you don't have to think like
you don't, you don't, I don't, you know,
I fucking sit, stand up,
stand tall at pocket.
Your first instinct is to
front for your fucking life.
You've lost half a step and then boom,
you take the next fucking hit and
now you fucked. Now you're fucked.
And that's the end of your career.
And hopefully you got three years in.
So you got the pension, which is something
we learned last night, three years.
He could play three seasons and then
you get the NFL pension, you know,
which starts at 55 for bastards.
And it's right around the time
when you fucking concussion system.
I don't have to pay. Do you really
know that for back? No, I don't.
Just shut the fuck up though.
So anyways,
the Patriots at 3.0 and uh,
how about those bills yesterday,
how they Keyala came to life.
All those people in Buffalo who were
ready to say to the big flounder there,
whatever his fucking name is.
I love that.
I can't remember Rex Ryan because he's
been so fucking quiet over the years.
They were all ready to tell him they hit
the fucking bricks. A rich, very rich.
Why don't you and your fucking
carnival ride looking brother,
right?
He looks like he runs like the tilt world.
Why don't you guys go down to Duffy's,
get yourself some wings, blood up,
bring your bags, bring your bags. This
is going to be a one way ticket. Okay.
Get on a fucking bus and go to Toronto
and take over the fucking argonauts cake
you're in when you're coaching the buffalo
bills. If you fucking lose that job,
if you get fired from that fucking job,
the next stop.
It's not even college football.
You're, you're in the CFL. And um,
I usually say no disrespect,
but I mean,
that is disrespectful as
possible towards the CFL. Okay.
And here's the deal. Nobody
in Canada gives a fuck. Okay.
They're all about the hockey. You
know, something. Speaking of that,
I missed all the world championship
hockey, like a fucking asshole.
Okay.
I heard it was amazing.
All right.
Sorry man,
I can't do my podcast.
I don't have to type in the
fucking password at the same time.
What was I talking about?
So about rex, right,
and fucking World World Cup hockey,
whatever the fuck that is.
I was making fun of the CFL. Hey
Bill, we all know what you were doing.
You're the one who lost his
fucking place. I right. Relax.
Still reason to get
hostile. So I think, um,
I dunno with Edelman at quarterback,
which is what it's looking like.
It is a home game.
I say this is my prediction,
knowing nothing about football on
any professional level, I say if,
if Jimmy Garappolo his
back, uh, we win that game.
I think if I don't know anybody else's
playing, I don't know, but said,
I don't know if he can play.
MMM.
I just think, I just think it's, it's,
that's going to be a really tough
one because what's his face?
Rex Ryan has a fucking hard on forest
and he's got a great defense and uh,
it looks like they, you know,
I don't really know this,
this year has been really fucking weird.
Like you'd see like,
like Arizona cardinals beat the
fuck out of the Seahawks, right?
Yeah.
And then you think, I'm like,
wow, they beat the Seahawks.
I know that they don't have Marshawn
lynch and all these guys are kind of a
different area then one of those weird
years and I'm not great, not fucking bad,
but they got Pete Carroll,
but they beat the fuck out of them and
then they go to buffalo there hasn't won
a game and then they get the shit
kicked out of them by the bill. So I, I,
this is too early in the season.
I don't know who's who.
I don't know what's what I dunno shot.
I don't know who's not,
but I think it's going to
be a really tough game. Um,
and I really hope that we
win because, uh, if we lose,
I know that Rex Ryan is going to
do some classless fucking, uh,
you know, one of his corny
as John Wayne fucking lies.
Nothing worse than a fat guy was swagger.
Um,
it's, I'm such a Dick Sometimes.
Oh my God. Bless him. Alright,
here we go. Let's do some advertising.
Lost another one. Everybody.
I lost another advertiser.
You know what I mean?
Date is don't fucking let those fucking
kids who were sitting there trying to go,
hey, did you know that 60% of
live event tickets go on sold?
I mean Jesus fucking Christ. It's one
of the dumbest things I've ever heard.
Yep.
What about,
Hey,
do you know that 60% of tickets are held
back and sold to fucking people like
you by the promoters that then get a cut
to the scalp and tickets on their own
fucking shows? I would
believe that because I don't
understand how these kind of,
these people end up with
all the God damn tickets.
Yeah.
Does that make any sense?
Is that you with your tail or is there
something knocking on the door to Cleo?
Yeah.
Huh?
What's your deal man?
You got Restless Dog Syndrome.
Fucking love this animal.
You know what Cleo,
I catch you on a big Tupperware except by
wouldn't let you go. Poo who? All right,
let's do some reads here. Let's do some
reads. All right. Give me the loop.
A loot crate,
loot crate looking for gear,
collectibles,
housewares in more from your favorite
pop culture franchises or we got your
cupboard.
Well we got you covered it.
A little crate offers a range of Geek
and Gamer items for less than 20 bucks a
month. Um, I want to bring
your loot to the next level.
Get a bigger box with even
bigger lute with loot crate DX.
If you're more the type to where
your geeky heart on your sleeve,
then loop where our monthly wearables.
Are you an accessory subscription?
Is the droids you're looking
for this fucking copy?
I have no idea other
than I've read it before.
I would have no idea what the fuck this
shit is. This is all that comic con.
You're going to comic con are you
sick of having the same costume?
Is every other fucking fat
unfuckable Geek down there?
Well we got you covered with
limited edition green lantern
and this is like this,
this place you could actually probably
dress up like Alfred the butler.
You know what I mean?
Like,
this is the level of fucking nerd shit
that they have here that she'll up.
Your spine isn't just your imagination.
It's Lou crates.
October theme horror.
We're taking over.
We've were taken over 40 years of creepy.
Can't be bloody icons and putting
them in this month's crape channel.
Your best final girl.
Okay.
With items from the walking dead.
What is final girl mean?
Nightmare on elm street. I know that
I'm on Friday the 13th. Absolutely.
Texas chainsaw massacre. Nice
and Halloween. Any bad? Well,
it's been a while since they've
made a good horror movie.
How they got to go that far back?
Uh,
you have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific
to subscribe and receive that month's
crate and when the, the cutoff
happens that that's it. It's over.
Make sure to head down to
www dot [inaudible] dot com
slash burr and enter the
code bird to save $3 off on
any new subscription today.
It was all in capitals.
I guess I was supposed to try
to scare you guys with that.
I have no idea what that is, but I want
to sell anybody who's into that. You. You,
you have fun with that. You have fun
with that. Whatever the fuck that is.
Oh, fucking excited. Oh my
God. It's, Oh my God. Jj.
It's Halloween's my Mavali.
I'm going to get a Mike Myers match.
I'm going to get Freddy Krueger.
[inaudible].
Should I be who you are going
to be this year? Well, can I,
I didn't want to be Jason.
Yeah,
you just put on a hockey mask and
you grab a knife in me and I just,
I feel like you know, I really, I want
to go all out. All right. Blue Apron,
everybody. Blue Apron. [inaudible] mission
is to make incredible home cooking.
Incredible home cooking accessible
to everyone. Jesus Christ.
What the fuck's going on upstairs?
Blue Apron achieves this by supporting
a more sustainable food system,
setting the highest
standards for agreements and
building a community of home
chefs.
Blue Apron has established
partnerships with over 150 local farms,
fisheries and ranchers from across the
United States. Well, that would be nice.
It would be nice if there was 150
farms left that the fucking oh Anthony,
Monsanto and aid took them
over as a result. Okay.
Seafood is sourced sustainably.
Understanders developed in a partnership
with the Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood
Watch. I don't know what that is.
You should look that up. Beef,
chicken and pork come from
responsibly raised animals.
This is all vague because blue apron
ships the exact amount of each ingredient
required for our recipe. They are
reducing food waste. I these guys go,
they got their heart in the right place.
Cooking together builds a
strong family bond resort of,
we're not gonna bring up Jesus.
Now are we?
Research shows that Blue Apron families
cook nearly three times more often.
Some of the meals available in September.
Uh,
we have the eggplant and chick pea Tan
Jain with islander pepper and tomato and
couscous. Uh, one of our
other specials is, um,
the summer udon noodle
with cherry tomatoes,
corn and summer sweet pepper.
And of course my favorite,
a peanut butter and Jelly Sandwich,
an artisan bread cooked by little
elves inside of a termite list tree.
All,
all the elves are,
are held against their will
in a responsible way for
less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with their pre portioned ingredients
to make delicious home cooked meal.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/bar
you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home cooked
meals with blue apron. So don't wait.
Yukon's that's blue apron.com/bar.
All right,
I'd love to be a fucking weight.
I just realized that.
Just mock the menu every night.
Um,
we have a theremin third,
a third theremin. Thalomid
what do you want? Their Fucko all right,
harming one of these. I got MVMT watches.
All right. When you're in your early
twenties and thirties, money can be tight,
man. If you're not careful, dressing,
welcome quickly. Drain your bank account,
like spending four to 500 bucks
on a department store. Watch.
There's some brands out there that charge
insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it. Well, if you want
to look great and when you go out,
but still have enough money
to buy him or her a drink,
people have told me that there also,
when they say him or her,
they mean you know if the guy is gay.
That's why they say him or her,
which is way more believable to me
that there's actually a woman out there
buying a man a drink.
Who knows?
I'm an old guy. Maybe. Maybe these
ladies have changed. Checkout Movement,
watches.com I've seen them before
and these watches are sharp.
I didn't,
I mean I read that,
I never said that originally founded by
two broke college kids movement watches
cut out the middle man and they're big
brand retail markups in order to give you
a stylish watch for an
affordable price movement.
Watches start at just 95 bucks a watch
with department store quality for a
fraction of the price.
There are sleek and minimalistic.
A modern twist on a classic style
movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like you. So join there more
than 1 million social media followers,
followers, followers, and get a
movement. Watch today. How I'll tell you,
go to MVMT watches.com/burr and they'll
give you 15% off your entire purchase.
MVMT watches.com/burr. Is this
the last one? No, it isn't.
It's still got two more to do
with, we'll wait. We will wait,
right?
No, no. There's only one more. I will plow
through this one. Fuck. All right. Oh,
our old favorite stamps.com
mailing and shipping.
Our routine part of your
business, uh, important.
Keeps your operations going.
That doesn't make any mailing and shipping
our routine part of your business.
Running your business. dot.dot. Important
Comma keeps your operation going.
This is like they giving clues
on a $10,000 pyramid routine.
Part of running your
business, uh, important, uh,
keeps your operation going. Pass, pass.
But if you're making constant
trips to the post office,
that's the routine that needs to change.
There's a much more convenient way,
and that's called stamps.com.
stamps.com brings all of the service
of your post office right to your desk.
You'll never waste valuable time
going to the post office again.
So you can focus on what really
matters, man, growing your business.
I use stamps.com to send out all the
posters for my fucking shows right now and
if I can figure it out.
So can you right now sign up for
stamps.com he used my last name,
birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer
that includes postage and a digital
scale. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are that stamps.com to birth.
Thank Christ. All right, it's over.
Okay.
So last week I teased you guys and I
mentioned something about great white
sharks. I was supposed to
go on this fucking trip, um,
with a good buddy of mine, Dean del
Rey. I paid for the whole fucking trip.
Um, well my, my part of the
trip I should say, and it was,
I was going to go on a shark cage and
while they chummed the fucking water and I
was going to what great white sharks
swimming by me, I was all set to go.
Everything was a go in all of this shit.
And then this fucking business,
um, you know, there was this edit in this
fucking, I just couldn't get out of it.
And I had,
I couldn't fucking go
and I was devastated,
but I'm happy that I got
done what needed to get done.
And if you guys want to see what I
missed out on, go to Dean del Rey's.
I'm sure he's already uploading
pictures. He's getting back now. And um,
he actually,
he's the reason why I went,
cause he went years ago and do like the
pictures look like discovery channel
Shit. And I'm terrified to
fucking sharks. But I also,
I want to see a great white shark at
some point in my life and to the universe
and a safe fucking way. I don't know,
being on a sinking ship and be like, oh,
I finally got to say,
right.
So I wasn't able to do it. Uh, but I,
so not only do I not get to do this,
okay.
And I ended up having to edit all these
fucking episodes and shit because even
though the show isn't coming out
until the spring of next year,
we're still in crunch time because
that's how doing a show works.
There's never enough time. There's
never enough money. They can't fucking,
it's just, it's just in,
you're always behind. Some we,
we just have to fucking get this
done now or we're going to be fucked.
We're going to be fucked. It's just,
it's just that 24, seven. Right?
So I'm glad that I did that,
but, uh, uh, fucking blows.
So anyway, so I'm back here. All right.
I'm driving around Los
Angeles and at rush hour, um,
I pull up to this fucking stoplight and
it's like, there's two lanes of cars.
All right? There's like two
people in front of me. I stop
and next to me, you know,
there's three people and that's as far,
you know,
I don't even look in the rear view mirror
and I'm just sitting there. One, 1000,
two, 1000, three, 1000, four, 1000.
And then I hear what sounds
like a fucking explosion.
Just boom. And I went, whoa. And
then I get, I don't even remember it,
somebody hit my car, right? I
don't even remember feeling that.
All I know is I just saw this fucking
Prius just driving right down the fucking
middle of all of this stop cars.
Just, just went right by me.
Sorry about years right there just right
and just side view fucking mirrors.
Just flying off every car right
down the side of my car and,
and he just comes to our,
he or she comes to a stop.
All the airbags deployed in
this person's car on the side.
I couldn't even see who was in it.
Okay.
So all I'm thinking is like,
oh my God,
fucking obviously classic example of
texting while driving is mother fucker was
looking down and at the last second
was like fuck and just tried to shoot
through the middle. So I, you know,
I hate when people get into
a little fender benders
like that and then they just
get out of their car and they leave
the car where it's at. It's like,
well you just drive
the fucking thing over,
get it out of the fucking way so
people behind you can get out of there.
So what I did was I pulled, I, you
know, there was like a street, you know,
a couple of feet up and I just pulled
into that street and pulled over and the
person still hasn't gotten out of the car.
Everybody else that this person
hit is out of their cars now.
And we're waiting for this person to get
out. And I'm thinking like, oh my God,
like are they unconscious?
Did they hit their fucking head?
I mean that really soundly
impact was unbelievable. Right?
I get out of my car and all I have is
this on the side of my car. All he did,
the person God was the side view mirror,
but it's bent all the way the fuck back.
So like basically you could pull up
next to me and you could like brush your
teeth in the mirror because it's,
it's pointed right at right at you.
A few parallel to me. So finally
the fucking car door opens and I,
and I actually felt bad for the
person. I was like, oh my God,
they're going to be so embarrassed.
They're going to be fucking mortified or
whatever. And it was the exact opposite.
This dude gets out and he just
starts cursing everybody out.
He got out of the car yelling at us.
It's fucking guy just hit five people.
He's like, your mother fucking fucking,
he's going fuck you. You fucking bitch.
You people. Now of course people are
videoing videoing this person. All right?
And he starts, you fucking
bitch. You fucking,
this is the person you
should be good video of her.
You fucking fuck all you guys.
And while I'm like,
this guy was like,
he was so fucking committed to
yelling at us for half a second.
I started thinking like, yeah, what,
what did I do wrong when I was
sitting there at the time traffic,
like not hitting any but so
the funniest thing ever, right?
These people start to engage
this person and the argument,
it's like,
why would you waste your time arguing?
This guy just hit five people with
the car and he's yelling at us.
He's literally knee deep
inside view fucking mirrors.
Like you really think that you're gonna,
you're going to say anything to this
guy and he's going to stop mid screaming
and be like, ah, yeah, okay,
fair enough. That's a good point.
Then look at it that way.
Um, so I just start laughing.
I mean it was, it was just,
it was fucking Alinsky.
I just hit five fucking people and
now he's yelling at us. It was,
it was fucking hilarious.
Right?
So he gets into his car and he grabs
like three backpacks and he puts them on
himself and he goes,
get used to it.
This is what this is what La is going to
be like. And everybody's like, Whoa, hey,
hey,
post nine 11 what the fuck does that mean?
He yells at the lady more calls her
a bitch and other couple of times,
and I don't know if they were both fucking
jockeying for a position or he felt
she cut him off, but I think this guy
just went total fucking road rage.
He just picked a spot and he's like,
I'm fucking getting there before
you and I don't give a shit.
This guy just fucking snaps.
So he grabs his fucking backpacks
and then just walks away,
walks down the street like fucking,
I was joking.
My buddies like Andy Griffith when
he's taken opie to go fishing,
he just fucking walked away and I was
like, this guy's out of his fucking mind.
He just Egypt, he just fuck.
He hit l he kept us,
he's yelling at us and he walks
away like I'm done with this shit.
Like one of the greatest displays of
entitlement I've ever seen in my fucking
life. I mean, what if there
was a pregnant lady hit? I mean
this guy hit this fucking first
person so hard. I looked down,
I thought it was a hubcap.
Who's this chunk of a rim?
I said to the cop that goes,
that plastic. He goes, no, that's metal.
That's the rim. It's like Jesus Christ.
So he, by the time the cops get
there, that guy has just gone.
He is gone. That ball is gone. Um,
so I call up a buddy of mine,
cause now I'm like fucking
piss going like Jesus.
Fuck with the arrogance of this guy. And
then I'm thinking all that shit. I just,
what? What if it went up? And I just
said, no buddy, you shut the fuck up.
And then I knocked him out and then have,
you know,
you're going to see a hero fucking thing.
Yeah. What if I did that? Oh wait that.
Sorry. I'm a pussy. You
know. Oh wait, I've have, uh,
I don't like getting punched in the face.
Oh,
that's why I don't have even a
white belt in any martial art.
That vow. That's why, that's why I sat
there and did nothing. Oh, I forgot.
That's right. That's why
I did nothing. Right.
So I call up a buddy of
mine who was a lawyer.
I remember a long time ago,
I got into it, this woman.
Okay.
And, uh, we went up to the stoplight
and she was like, you know,
she beeped at me. So I beat back at her
and she beat to me, I'd be back to her.
And then she just fucking hammered
the horn all the way up to the light,
like 400 yards,
bay stops and holds it down and
staring at me in the rear view mirror.
Wow.
And the second it stopped,
she held her horn down for 30 seconds
and the second is stopped. I just went
and me and the woman I was with fucking
started dying laughing at her and then
she all of a sudden put her car in
reverse, backed into me really lightly,
and then get out at, reached into our
glove box. And I sat there like going,
oh my God, is she getting
a gun? What the fuck?
And she wrote down my license
plate number and then drove away.
And I of course thought nothing of it.
I was a young man.
Okay.
And next thing you know, I'm on the
road and I get this, I check in my bump,
checking my voicemail. It's like the
90s. This is a long ago. This was,
and it was just like, yeah. Uh, Mr. Bird,
this is a officer so and so from the
Elsa Gundo priest police department
investigating a possible
assault with a deadly weapon,
uh, or whatever the fuck it is. Because
basically your car is a deadly weapon.
Not Is it a battery?
If you actually hit somebody,
I thought it was salt was
either threatening somebody
or making them feel like
you're going to hit him or
something like that. That salt in,
in a battery assault and battery
is actually doing it. So anyways,
because of that fucking thing,
mmm,
I knew that, you know, watching
this guy leave. I'm like, okay,
that's five councilman is salt off
of assault with a deadly weapon.
We got video of you
screaming and everybody see,
can't say you were texting
and listening to the radio.
You've basically admitted that what you
did, you kind of did on purpose. You,
we have you on video,
everyone knows what you look like and
then you left the scene of the accident.
So I call up a buddy of mine who was
a lawyer and I just left a message.
I just said, I just want to know what
kind of jail time is this guy looking at?
How long is he going to go
to jail? My buddy calls me
back and he just goes, I go,
yeah, I got to him fucking bleeding. He
goes, yeah man, it's crazy. And I go,
how long is this guy going to go to
jail for? Was that like three years?
And he goes, ah, you know,
he's a first offender. I
mean, the jails are crowded,
you know, he doesn't have any
other priors or anything like that.
He just has like a rage issue.
They probably just suspend his license
and definitely they send him some anger
management things in. And I
was just like, no jail time.
And he was like, when he got out of
the car, like what was he saying?
And maybe this, I couldn't wait. I was
like, you can, you can fucking hit people.
Five people,
five different people in a car,
no concern for that. Their wellbeing
whatsoever. Get out, curse everybody out.
Leave and not fucking go to jail.
It's unbelief. What the fuck do
you have to do to go to jail?
And he was just like,
well,
you're going to put him in jail and nobody
becomes a better person when they go
to jail. He's going to be in there
with a bunch of fucking maniac.
So I actually feel irresponsible to
let people know out there that you can
basically do what this guy just did.
And you're not going to go to jail. I'm,
I mean, I'm sure he's going to
get arrested when they find them.
I Dunno. I was, I was
pretty blown away by that.
So there you go. Instead of looking at
sharks, I got rear ended by this guy.
But uh, I to admit, every time
I think about that guy yelling,
it was fucking hilarious.
And I start thinking like,
was that just like a strategy for
him to get the fuck out of there?
And everybody goes like he boobs a
probably a stolen car. It's like,
who the fuck steals a Prius?
How do you start a Prius?
How do you steal what you can you
hot wire the fucking thing. I,
I dunno.
I have no idea.
So I love it becomes like a
fucking sleuth, you know? Well,
we have probably what you, what was,
what was the circumstances? Oh, okay.
Let me listen to you with
your complete lack of fucking,
that's why I called the lawyer was like,
I don't want to talk to
other people's every,
you'd probably get like shoving years,
you know,
I never even took a a lawyer class.
Lower class. I never went to law school.
I'm a moron.
All right.
I'm also trying to type in my password
so I immediately become extra fucking
stupid. Did I type it in right?
Did I type it in right? Yes. Okay.
Let's do some questions here for the week,
or by the way,
congratulations to the Tennessee
volunteers, man. Jesus Christ.
What a fucking game versus
Florida SCC football ad.
It's fucking best.
They hadn't beat Florida in 11 years.
They can't close a couple of times
only to come up short, right?
So Tennessee got their asses,
what? In the first fucking half,
they get booed off the field
by their own fan base, right?
They come out,
they make their halftime adjustments and
all of a sudden the scoring in the game
stops.
It's like 21 to three Tennessee couldn't
do a fucking thing with the ball.
But now all of a sudden Florida can't,
you know,
they're still up 21 three but then at
scorn anymore and they're getting stops
and all of a sudden Tennessee
starts moving the fucking bomb.
They score 2110 the crowd starts coming
to life. All right? They get another stop.
Florida's defense goes back out in
the field. They're getting tired,
right? The next thing you know, fucking
Bam, Bam, Bam, like Mister Blonde,
a lot of reservoir dogs
references this week fucking,
they just went on this fucking run and
they like 506 drives still last drives,
they scored touchdowns and next thing
you know it's fucking like 38 to 21 or
something like that.
And there's like a minute and a
half left and one of the coolest,
I said they went up into Tennessee's like
the coach's box when they're up there,
you know the guys down there, the
fucking the generals up there, right.
And um, they, they circled this
one guy, Gary Danielson circles.
This one guy goes,
you see this guy right here?
And they had this total intense
look on his face. He goes,
that guy was brought to Tennessee
for one reason to beat Florida.
And it's just like,
that's the fucking shit.
That's like one of the bad aesthetic.
Like what are you doing here?
What are you doing here in Knoxville?
And you can,
you can actually legitimately
sit at a bar and be like,
I came to Knoxville for one reason
and that's to be Florida. Um,
and not be totally, it wouldn't
be, it wouldn't be as cheesy said,
you could actually fucking be
telling the truth so that you guys,
we brought in for one reason
and that was to beat Florida.
And the fucking guy did it and he
showed no emotion until three, two,
one and then resolve. He jumped up and
hugged the guy next to him. That's just,
you know,
I can't imagine how much money is getting
stuffed in the front pocket of his
fucking button down by all, by all
those boosters. The poster span,
um, bought a fucking game.
People were going fucking crazy.
It was just a,
it was just one of the,
Joe was every Verne Lundquist said,
he said, if, you know, if you,
if you don't lock that you
don't like college football.
He didn't have a southern accent, but I
just, I dunno, it was Tennessee man. Um,
and once again, bucket list, you know, I
want to go to a Florida gator home game,
which I'm fucking going to in
a couple of weeks against Lsu,
I'm speaking of which,
uh,
happy trails as they say
on a PTI to a less Myers,
had a great fucking run there. I
mean, that's how it always ends.
It always ends with you
getting fired. So, uh,
as much as people bitch Moan
and complain about the guy,
he did win a championship and l people
who there was Nick Saban's team, oh,
go fuck yourself. You know? Okay. So it
was Nick Saban's team and you know what?
He didn't drive it into a fucking tree
and they missed the playoffs. You know,
like a certain guy who went 11 and five
with the Patriots the year after the
fucking super bowl. Um,
the Matt Cassel debate,
holy fucking shit. That, that
will never end. Dude met castle
or what about when he went
to Kansas City and they,
he was so bad that they cheered
when he fucking got hurt. Well,
that was because that was Kansas City.
Well,
Joe Montana went to Kansas City
and all of a sudden, Kansas City,
he went to the playoffs.
Playoffs. All right.
I just don't know how fucking more
basic it could be, but now you're right,
Matt Cassel, Tom Brady, Qantas. There's
no difference. Oh, Jesus. Alright.
Hypodermics hydro phonics.
Um, dear Billy Baldo,
the bollock brain bullet,
brain bolt pro football wall.
Uh, I'm having a real problem
in a startup I'm launching.
I'm pitching that about hydro phonics
to people who have no idea about it.
Is this like a commercial that's
disguised as a fucking question?
How can I make it relatable
to the common man?
It's the best way to grow plants using
the leased land and water with much less
chemicals. Oh Dude, you fucking
with blue blood money here.
If you better keep this under wraps
do or you'll just let her know,
commit suicide somehow.
Conveniently I made an invention that's
slashes the cost to less than half of
the current system,
but pitching it and getting people
interested is a big challenge. Any advice?
Um,
yeah,
I would do what the guide the Tesla guy
did you just do it yourself because you
like the best case scenario is if what
you're doing is true is you'll pitch it
to a corporation, they will buy
it and they will never use it,
but they will own it and
then no one else can use it.
Like that's what they would do.
Um,
okay.
So anyways, he said, uh, a Duh.
Any advice the hydro phonics can really
change the global farming for the
better. Saw your show in Bristol with
my team and really enjoyed it. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Um, yeah, I would try.
You need to find for something like that,
I would say that you need to find people
that are, you need to find the rebels.
All right?
Those rare people who
actually have money and um,
aren't giving it to politicians,
aren't best friends with all the fucking
cops and just totally in the system.
You got to find people outside of
that who want to be like, yeah,
this is bullshit. Uh, coming here with
an idea and mind, let's try to fucking,
but the book I'm gonna,
you're probably gonna have to
give up part ownership of it. Um,
there's all of that, but uh, you know,
if what you're saying is
actually real and it does work,
I would save and if you
owned a piece of that,
you're going to be fine
financially. But, um,
now how you find those types of people?
I have no idea.
But what I would try to do,
I mean,
can you literally Google the top 10
fucking people with money that you know,
ah, Jesus Christ, this is all going off
the rails. You know what I'm saying?
I would not go the corporate
route cause like I said there,
you're either going to fucking,
you know,
they'll put something in your eggs and
you'll have a fucking coronary, um,
or, uh, they're just going to buy
the idea and take it. So I, you need,
you need to find some rebels, man.
People with some fucking balls.
Eh, uh, then I would try to
go directly to local farmers,
show them how it works.
Uh,
you might have to give it
away at first and then he,
that guy will spread the word
to other farmers and you know,
this could be a way that they can compete,
compete with big time farming.
Okay.
You know, like, I would try
to sell it that way. Uh,
that's one of those things you
gotta do it. Like, you know,
like how the other rappers
would make it back in the day,
they'd make mix tapes and sell
them out of the trunk of their car.
Like you have to do it that way. This
is a, this is going to the long road.
You know what I mean? This is the
comic who doesn't have a catch phrase,
who doesn't wear the same silly fucking
shirt every time. Who fucking isn't like,
Oh, you know the Hague. I Dunno,
it doesn't wrap their fucking
act around a cause. Um,
you just going to be,
try to just be funny.
You're going to have to take
the long road with this, but um,
okay.
Yeah, I think in the, in there
I want something somewhere.
I gave you some good advice.
Yeah.
I would try to get to local farmers
and have one of them use it and say how
great it is and how much, how much
money they saved. I would go that way.
And then you get enough of those
farmers doing that shit. Okay.
Using your system and
then you get them to,
to show their results and what they were
able to do and how much more money they
made using less. And then
Dan, you go to the guy,
then you start asking around,
then you find the guy, then
you get the money. Okay.
Now you've got a little bit of momentum
because you did some of the legwork.
You can own more of it and then you
can create that feel like, hey man,
I got another guy coming
down to check this out.
You want to get business with me?
What? Then you get a better percentage.
I would go that route nine.
You know, I basically,
I just described like a Julia Roberts
movie, but I think you could do it.
All right. Anyways, good luck to you sir.
I hope what you're saying is true and I
hope you can make a difference because
that would be tremendous.
All right. Bay or cons. Hey,
coppertop was wa wondering if
you heard about these cons? Bear?
Yeah, the aspirin. Oh yeah, I heard about
this. These fuckers are buying, oh, Annie,
Monsanto and changing their name to bear
to avoid the negativity that comes with
the Monsanto name,
but not changing any of the fucked up
practices like GMO seeds and hiding from
the public how they are poisoning
our food supply, et cetera. Yeah.
How come this never comes up in the
political debates they'd have a talk about
because these guys have so much they have,
we will fucking murder you money if you
talk to talk to us, talk about us. Um,
as this,
this wasn't bad enough.
I read up on bear and come
to find out a few years ago,
these bastards supplied
blood to hemophiliacs who
needed blood transfusions and
their products and had the aids
virus ended and continue to sell it.
After they knew about it, they
even admitted to it. Come on.
What did you read this?
What? What in the fuck?
How are these corporate fuckheads
always allowed to get away with this
unbelievable level of greed
and solace in human behavior?
These kids should be tried and executed.
Here's the link in case you wanted
to read up on this bare admits,
it paid millions in HIV
infected infection cases just,
just not in English.
Well,
thanks for the last after reading shit
like this, I can use a few. All right,
I'll look that up.
I hope that's a legitimate website
and that's some fucking lunatic.
But that just says that they admitted
that they fucked up and paid out,
but God knows that
corporations, they, you know,
they had those fucking police cruisers.
That way if you got rear ended,
like there was a major problem with
the gas tank igniting in these state
troopers were fucking burning to death.
And I heard they knew about that and they
weighed the whole, well, the lawsuit,
the class action suit versus changing the
design and the class action suit would
be less. So they chose that
and they let these guys,
these fucking cops burned to death.
So it wouldn't surprise me.
This is getting really dark people.
All right.
Okay.
Hillary health, dear Billy Bilderberg, um,
I've always known you to be an o
on openminded and unbiased. Really?
Uh, I, that's not how I described myself
and also an empathizer with conspiracy
theories. Oh yeah, I'll
fucking all this a toy,
which is why I was somewhat upset about
your unawareness last week when asked
about Hillary's health unawareness.
Is that a word?
Uh, I'm not some guy. And, well
it didn't get underlined in red.
So obviously it's got to be a word,
right?
I'm not some guy in support
of either campaign or party.
Yes you are. We all are.
But when I saw the shit
I'm going to show you,
I slowly became more unhinged.
All I'm hoping for here is,
uh,
is to react to a few videos that have
received as limited media attention as
possible.
And I'll just try to give quick on
bias descriptions before each one.
But I want, uh, you to
give your honest opinion.
I'm sure you might have the same first
thought that I had after seeing these
things, but eventually the only reaction
is I had a, what the fuck is happening?
Just put them in a URL.
Click on him. All right.
Yeah.
Okay. And what he's describing all
this stuff. All right. Seizure faces.
Okay.
Phlegm faints in green screen.
All right,
so I watched these videos.
Yeah.
Let me see if I can find these things.
These are all clips of
Hillary Clinton allegedly, uh,
you know,
having major medical issues and, and
nobody's talking about. All right.
Did Hillary have a seizure?
All right.
You guys have got a tribe and cold.
I don't, I don't think she had
a seizure in this first one.
I think she is that uncomfortable in her
own fucking skin and that's her trying
to act like she's fucking playful and
this is what all politicians do and this
is why Trump is killing it. Because
Trump would have looked over and be like,
where the fuck did you come from? She did
not just have it. That's not a seizure.
Okay,
that's not what a seizure looks like.
You don't have a seizure like fucking,
yeah,
they will jump on anything.
There's no fucking way like
the media is going to cover up.
She had a fucking seizure.
Gimme a thug.
How much they made out of her having
pneumonia. That's not a seizure.
That's just an incredibly uncomfortable
person in their own fucking skin trying
to act like they're playful. All
right, this next one's my favorite one.
Close up of Hillary's feet showing
she was dragged into event.
Now this one's completely eliminated
because you never show me who's head
belongs to those feet.
It's somebody getting dragged,
like I don't understand.
Like I don't even see her get,
I don't even see that person's for me.
Look at this again. See the, she's,
they're getting dragged here.
Yeah. I don't see anything there. And
I don't even know that that's Hillary.
This is why you can't, we can't
present this as fucking news. Um,
then Hillary disappearing. This looks
like a fifth grade Photoshop to me.
Yeah. I don't know this, this is fucking
hilarious. This looks like an Atari from,
this is why this is not on national
news, Dude. This shit is ridiculous.
And then the last one is simply her with
her weird eyes. Normally in slow motion
with some silly music underneath it.
Yeah. No, this is, you put anybody in slow
motion. They're going to look demonic.
This is why I haven't talked
about it. Okay. Uh, yeah,
she's on the campaign trail.
She's worked herself to
death and she got pneumonia.
Like most people when
they work themselves, that
heart, you catch pneumonia.
It's completely fucking normal. Do I
agree with their politics? Do I like her?
Am I going to vote for her now?
Am I going to vote for Donald Trump?
Now is the other person that I'm going
to fucking vote for going to win now.
All right.
But I don't think that Hillary is like
literally having seizures on TV and uh,
people are just completely
fucking ignoring it. All right?
There's plenty of fucking dopes that they
can put in office that will do exactly
what they say that don't have seizures.
So why would they have her?
Cause it's too late, man. That too far
down the thing. Yeah. I don't buy it.
I am all about the conspiracies.
I'm all fuck him about them. I, you know,
but I, I don't, I just don't buy into it.
So what I think you have
there, sir, is, um, basically,
you know those shows where people
find old shit in their house.
Like this has been in our family
for like five generations.
I was wondering is it worth anything?
And sometimes it is, sometimes it isn't.
You're a,
you're that person who came in with
something that you thought it was real,
but it's a fake and you thought it was
worth thousands and thousands of dollars.
But it's, sorry, it's only worth 15 bucks.
Yeah.
And then you just,
and the awkward silence that follows you
just slowly pack up your shit and then
you leave. I'm sorry sir. I wanted to
believe it's so bad I can't stand Hillary.
I think she is one of the most dishonest
people that has come along since her
husband or the last Bush administration.
Um,
I hate the Clintons. I hate the bushes.
I don't mind the George Bush senior.
All right. George Bush senior
was a fucking bad ass. Okay.
I don't know what the fuck the Warren
Commission and being part of the CIA,
I don't know what the fuck he did there.
All I knew is that guy at like 19 years
old fucking bombed an island where he
had this fucking fly in and what he was
trying to take out was below the highest
points. It was like he's flying
into an old football stadium,
shaped like a horse shoe.
And he flew in below the highest level
of the mountains and the side of him.
And there was people shooting at
him down at his fucking plane.
You got it. You got? What the
fuck was the flags of our fathers?
You gotta read that book now, that
book I read. Um, anyways. All right,
that is the podcast,
ladies and gentlemen. Uh,
thank you so much for listening and uh,
that is all checkout Dean del Ray's
pictures of the shark and counter that I
missed, but next year I'm
definitely fucking going. I
delayed it for a year. Um,
what happened? He can't fucking
do everything, but uh, you know,
I'm glad I was here and I got to edit
the shows and to get rear ended by a
psycho and watched the guy just walk
away. Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boo.
Right down the fucking
streets. There you go, people.
She's now that you can do that.
If you're having a bad day of a Deli,
you can plow into five people,
tell them to all go fuck
themselves and you just walk away.
But they will take your license forever.
Possibly if they find you.
I have no idea. All right. Go
fuck yourselves and I'll check on,
on Thursday. As always, if you
want to donate to the podcast,
the easiest way to do it as you go to
the [inaudible] dot com you click on the
podcast page and then you
click on the Amazon blink,
and if you go there and take an Amazon,
if you buy something,
no extra charge to you,
they kicked me a little fucking dough
for a driving traffic to their site.
If you don't want to do it,
I totally understand. All
right, I'll see you Thursday.